Make every get-together chill. This Memorial Day, get up to an extra $1,000 off select top brand appliances like LG. Plus, get free delivery at the Home Depot. Tackle pool towels and camp laundry with a large capacity washer. And host and style with the fridge-serving craft ice, mini-craft ice, cube ice, and crushed ice. Shop appliance savings now through June 3rd at the Home Depot. Offer valid May 14th through June 3rd, US-only. Free delivery on appliance purchases of $998 or more.
让每一次聚会都轻松惬意。这个阵亡将士纪念日，购买LG等精选顶级品牌家电，最高可享1000美元额外优惠。此外，在家得宝（Home Depot）还可享受免费送货服务。用大容量洗衣机轻松搞定泳池毛巾和露营衣物。用配备精酿冰块、迷你精酿冰块、方块冰和碎冰功能的冰箱来招待宾客，尽显格调。即日起至6月3日，在家得宝选购家电，享受优惠。优惠有效期为5月14日至6月3日，仅限美国地区。家电消费满998美元及以上可享免费送货。
See Store Online for details. This year, more than 120 million Americans watched the Super Bowl on television, the biggest single-network telecast audience in history. Okay, some of those viewers might have tuned in to see Taylor Swift, but a lot of them were there for the football. Almost 40% of Americans say that they follow sports somewhat or very closely, according to a 2023 Pew Research Center poll. And about 7% of them are super fans who, follow sports extremely closely and talk about sports every day. You might know some of those super fans, or maybe you're one yourself. So whether it's college sports, the NFL, the WNBA, or Major League Baseball, what drives sports fans to become so passionately attached to their
详情请见店内或线上说明。今年，超过1.2亿美国人通过电视观看了超级碗，这是历史上单一电视网转播观众人数最多的一次。好吧，其中一些观众可能是为了看泰勒·斯威夫特，但很多人确实是为了橄榄球。根据皮尤研究中心2023年的一项民意调查，近40%的美国人表示他们或多或少非常关注体育运动。其中约7%是超级粉丝，他们极其关注体育，每天都在谈论体育。你可能认识一些这样的超级粉丝，或者你自己就是其中之一。所以，无论是大学体育、NFL、WNBA还是美国职业棒球大联盟，是什么驱使体育迷对他们的
teams? Is being a fan good for your mental health, even when your team is losing? Why are some people fair weather fans while others love to root for the underdog. What about aggression among sports fans? Why do some fans behave badly? Can playing in front of a big supportive crowd of fans actually affect a team's performance? In other words, is there really a home field advantage? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Dan Wan, a distinguished professor in the Department of Psychology at
球队产生如此强烈的依恋？即使球队输球，成为粉丝对心理健康有好处吗？为什么有些人是“看天吃饭”的粉丝，而另一些人却喜欢支持弱队？体育迷之间的攻击性又是怎么回事？为什么有些粉丝表现恶劣？在大量支持他们的粉丝面前比赛，真的会影响球队的表现吗？换句话说，真的存在主场优势吗？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是丹·万博士，他是心理学系的杰出教授，任职于
Murray State University in Murray, Kentucky. He's been studying the psychology of sports fans and spectators since the mid-1980s with a particular interest in fans' psychological connection to their teams. He's the author of more than 200 journal articles and multiple books, including sport fans, the psychology and social impact of fandom. His work has been covered by major media outlets, including ESPN, Time Magazine, The Washington Post, the New York Times, and Sports Illustrated. Dr. Juan is a research fellow in the Sport Marketing Association and has won many awards for his research and teaching. Dr. Juan, thank you for joining me today.
位于肯塔基州默里的默里州立大学。自20世纪80年代中期以来，他一直致力于研究体育迷和观众的心理，特别关注粉丝与球队之间的心理联系。他撰写了200多篇期刊文章和多部著作，包括《体育迷：粉丝文化的心理与社会影响》。他的研究被ESPN、《时代》杂志、《华盛顿邮报》、《纽约时报》和《体育画报》等主流媒体报道。胡安博士是体育营销协会的研究员，并在研究和教学方面获得了许多奖项。胡安博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。
Absolutely, my pleasure to be here. So let's start with the big question. Why do people become sports fans? What drives their intense attachment to a sport? or a particular team, or even an individual player. Yeah, that's so oftentimes the $2 million question, right? And anytime you have a $2 million question, you can end up with about two million different answers.
当然，很高兴来到这里。那么，让我们从一个大问题开始。为什么人们会成为体育迷？是什么驱使他们对某项运动、某支球队甚至某位球员产生强烈的依恋？是的，这通常是那个价值200万美元的问题，对吧？而且每当你遇到一个价值200万美元的问题时，你最终可能会得到大约200万个不同的答案。
So I think that given the time constraints that we might have, I actually teach an entire course on the sport fan psychology that we spend four months talking about this. But I think that a pretty straightforward answer would be to say that one thing that we know that sport phantom does is it really does help individuals meet basic psychological needs that sure you can say that okay so-and-so follow sport because well it's fun or because maybe it provides an escape from the stress of life or the boredom of their life or you know maybe in some way they enjoy the aesthetics of it the beauty and the grace and the artistic nature that come with some sport events but really what we've learned in the past
所以，考虑到我们可能有的时间限制，我实际上开设了一门关于体育迷心理学的完整课程，我们花了四个月的时间来讨论这个问题。但我认为一个相当直接的回答是，我们知道体育迷文化确实能帮助个人满足基本的心理需求。当然，你可以说，某人关注体育是因为这很有趣，或者因为它提供了一种逃避生活压力或无聊的方式，又或者他们以某种方式享受体育赛事带来的美感、优雅和艺术性。但实际上，在过去
about decade is we've sort of undersold ourselves in terms of the psychology of sport fandom, and it really does mean more than what we had previously thought. Some examples that I can come up with pretty quickly here would be, for example, by being a fan of a particular team or a sport or even a player, it gives that individual the opportunity to feel a sense of belongingness. We are very social creatures. Affiliation is certainly, you know, born in us through evolution. And one thing that fandom allows people to do is to get an impart of these groups. I mean, if you reside in a local community and you follow the local team, it's hard to feel lonely. It's hard to feel isolated, right?
十年里，我们学到的是，我们在体育迷心理学方面有些低估了自己，它确实比我们之前想象的意义更深远。我可以很快举出一些例子，例如，通过成为某支球队、某项运动甚至某位球员的粉丝，它让个人有机会感受到一种归属感。我们是非常社会化的生物。归属感当然是通过进化与生俱来的。粉丝文化让人们能够成为这些群体的一部分。我的意思是，如果你居住在当地社区并关注当地球队，就很难感到孤独。很难感到被孤立，对吧？
And it gives you this critical link to others. But the flip side is also that we don't want to be cookie cutters. We don't want to be exact because of everybody else. We like to stand out in some way, be unique in some way. And sport fandom also provides that. So it gives us this power to be distinct and unique. It's funny that when I talk to sports fans and given what I do, I do that quite frequently. I'll ask him, so who are your favorite teams? And let's say I'm talking to somebody who resides
它为你提供了与他人之间至关重要的联系。但另一方面，我们也不想成为千篇一律的人。我们不想因为和别人一样而变得毫无特色。我们喜欢以某种方式脱颖而出，以某种方式变得独特。体育迷文化也提供了这一点。所以它赋予了我们变得与众不同和独特的权力。有趣的是，当我与体育迷交谈时，鉴于我的工作，我经常这样做。我会问他们，谁是你最喜欢的球队？假设我正在和某位居住在
near Boston. They'll say, well, I love the Red Sox and I love the Celtics and I love the Patriots and I love Manchester United. You're like, wait, what? One of these things is not like the other. And it's so interesting because that one team allows them to just feel different from everybody else. So I would say that the most straightforward answer is that people are fans because it helps them meet these basic psychological needs. It's not the only way that they can meet these needs, but things like belongingness and the need for the distinction and the need for structure and the need for meeting in life. Fandom is well suited to help meet those types of needs. So what's the research? How do you study fans and find out technically that they really are benefiting mentally from being fans?
波士顿附近的人交谈。他们会说，我喜欢红袜队，我喜欢凯尔特人队，我喜欢爱国者队，我还喜欢曼联。你会想，等等，什么？这些东西里有一个和别的不同。这太有趣了，因为那支球队让他们感觉与众不同。所以我认为最直接的答案是，人们成为粉丝是因为这有助于他们满足这些基本的心理需求。这不是他们满足这些需求的唯一途径，但像归属感、对独特性的需求、对结构的需求以及对生活意义的需求，粉丝文化非常适合帮助满足这些类型的需求。那么研究结果是什么呢？你是如何研究粉丝并从技术上发现他们确实从成为粉丝中获得了心理上的益处？
Yeah, we do it so many ways. Like so many lines of research and psychology over the years, you find laboratory methods and you also find field research. We've done it in my research program, both ways we will, you know, engage the, as they've been referred to before, the prey of the social psychology research or your lovely psychology introductory students. But I also really like going out into the field and going to sporting events and talking. and talking to them and surveying them. I have a research team that pretty much every year we will pick specific sporting events around the area and we'll go to. And we always get with these people before the game because I don't want to interrupt their entertainment value as well. But we'll sit down, we'll pass out questionnaires, talk to them.
是的，我们通过很多方式来做。就像多年来心理学的许多研究方向一样，你会发现实验室方法，也会发现实地研究。在我的研究项目中，我们两种方式都用过。我们会让那些之前被称为社会心理学研究的“猎物”，也就是你们可爱的心理学入门学生参与进来。但我也非常喜欢走进实地，去体育赛事现场与他们交谈，并对他们进行调查。我有一个研究团队，几乎每年我们都会挑选该地区特定的体育赛事去现场。我们总是在比赛前与这些人接触，因为我也不想打扰他们的娱乐体验。但我们会坐下来，分发问卷，与他们交谈。
And I like doing that because it's in the moment for them. So if they're at the sporting event, sport is at that point in time saving to them. And I do think you get some more authentic responses than if they're sitting in a classroom and, you know, stressed out about the test they're about to take in two hours. So we will use all types of methods. We'll go to major sporting events. We'll go to minor sporting events. We'll go to youth sporting events.
我喜欢这样做，因为这对他们来说是当下的体验。如果他们在体育赛事现场，那么在那一刻，体育对他们来说就是重要的。而且我认为，比起让他们坐在教室里，为两个小时后要参加的考试感到压力，你能得到更真实的反应。所以我们会使用各种方法。我们会去大型体育赛事，去小型体育赛事，去青少年体育赛事。
Then we'll also, you know, just grab the random psychology student that's in a classroom. And does it matter to one's health, whether you're a fan of, you know, your kids' little league or a national team? Yeah, that's a great question. And what we find is it really does not. What is critical is the extent to which the person does identify with that team. A term that we will often throw out there in sports psych is team identification, which is simply the extent to which the fan feels some type of psychological connection to the team. How much is the team an extension of the fan? How central is that team and being a fan of that team to their own self or social identity? And what we found is across multiple studies and multiple levels of competition from youth sports, you know, college sports, high school sports all the way up to, you know, major professional sports in the Olympics, is that the more the fan is identified with a local team, the greater that that individual is likely to have a well-rounded sense of psychological health, lower levels of loneliness, lower levels of alienation, a higher sense of self-esteem, less social isolation.
然后我们也会随机抓取教室里的心理学学生。那么，无论你是你孩子小联盟的粉丝还是国家队的粉丝，这对一个人的健康有影响吗？是的，这是一个很好的问题。我们发现，这其实并没有区别。关键在于个人对该球队的认同程度。我们在运动心理学中经常提到的一个术语是“团队认同”，这仅仅是指粉丝对球队产生某种心理联系的程度。球队在多大程度上是粉丝的延伸？这支球队以及成为这支球队的粉丝在多大程度上是他们自我或社会认同的核心？我们通过多项研究和从青少年体育、大学体育、高中体育一直到主要职业体育和奥运会的多个竞争水平发现，粉丝对当地球队的认同感越强，该个人就越有可能拥有更全面的心理健康感，孤独感和疏离感更低，自尊心更强，社会孤立感更少。
And a critical point is it's not necessarily the team identification itself that drives this finding. It's the fact that if you identify with a local team, that identification brings with it a group that you can then belong to. And by then getting this sense of belonging, you're then going to get this sense that, well, you know what, I'm not alone in the world. and that's a great thing for our well-being. Again, to go back to Boston, if you're walking around a Boston mall here in the early spring
关键的一点是，并不一定是团队认同本身驱动了这一发现。事实是，如果你认同当地球队，这种认同会带来一个你可以归属的群体。通过获得这种归属感，你就会产生一种感觉，好吧，你知道吗，我在世界上并不孤单。这对我们的幸福感来说是一件好事。再次回到波士顿，如果你在早春时节走在波士顿的商场里
with a Boston Red Sox cap, people are talking to you, right? You've got all of these friends there at the mall. You don't know where they work. You don't know what their name is. You don't know where they live, but they're saying hi to you. It'd be really hard to feel lonely at that point in time.
戴着波士顿红袜队的帽子，人们会和你交谈，对吧？你在商场里有这么多朋友。你不知道他们在哪里工作。你不知道他们的名字。你不知道他们住在哪里，但他们会和你打招呼。在那一刻，你很难感到孤独。
The last point that I'll make is that we know that it's changing now, this sense of gaining psychological, health from fandom because of the digital age that we're in, you know, 15 years ago to follow a sport team and feel connected to others, you kind of had to live in that environment. You can watch a sporting event now from anywhere on the planet and plug in online and feel as though you're actually watching it with others. So we're being forced to change some of our thinking about how fan impacts well-being because, well, being a fan has changed over the last 15 and 20 years because of the social age.
我要说的最后一点是，我们知道现在这种从粉丝文化中获得心理健康的感觉正在发生变化，因为我们处于数字时代。你知道，15年前，要关注一支运动队并感到与他人有联系，你必须生活在那个环境中。现在你可以从地球上的任何地方观看体育赛事，在线接入，感觉就像你真的在和别人一起观看一样。所以我们被迫改变了一些关于粉丝如何影响幸福感的想法，因为在过去15到20年里，由于社交时代，成为一名粉丝的方式已经改变了。
What if your team is having a bad season? If you're a really passionate fan, can a loss or a bad season harm your mental health? I guess that would depend on how you would define harm your mental health. Most certainly it can make you cranky, upset, aggressive, hostile, violent, in a bad mood, surly. These were things that would be words that would describe me over the years following both the Cubs and the Kansas City Royals. I have a lot of expertise with following bad teams. I've kind of perfected it, as a matter of fact. The good news, I say, the bad news would be that, yes, certainly following sports teams,
如果你的球队表现不佳怎么办？如果你是一个非常热情的粉丝，输球或糟糕的赛季会损害你的心理健康吗？我想这取决于你如何定义“损害你的心理健康”。当然，这会让你变得暴躁、沮丧、好斗、敌对、暴力、心情不好、脾气暴躁。这些词可以用来形容我多年来关注小熊队和堪萨斯城皇家队时的状态。我在关注糟糕球队方面有很多经验。事实上，我已经完善了这一点。好消息是，我说，坏消息是，是的，当然，关注运动队，
because it is central to the identity of highly identified fans, it is going to matter. If you were to take away the emotional response of being a sport fan, you would take away the point of being a sports fan, right? I mean, to be a fan is to be emotional. the elation from the wind, the disappointment in the loss, and every potentially emotional range in between those two things. But if a fan feels disappointed at the loss, that's just a natural reaction. They care about these things. And, you know, the problem is they can't do a whole lot about it, right?
因为它对高度认同的粉丝的身份认同至关重要，所以它肯定会有影响。如果你要剥夺体育迷的情感反应，你就剥夺了成为体育迷的意义，对吧？我的意思是，成为粉丝就是要有情感。从胜利的喜悦，到失败的失望，以及介于这两者之间的每一个潜在的情感范围。但如果粉丝对失败感到失望，那只是自然的反应。他们关心这些事情。而且，你知道，问题是他们对此无能为力，对吧？
They put their heart and soul into following the team, and they're just this idle spectator going, well, I sure hope things go in my direction today. It's not exactly like, I'm the one shooting the free throw or I'm the one swinging the bat. So they had this sort of sense of helplessness that can intensify the frustration when they lose. But if that occurs, the beauty of it is that nobody, I think, has perfected coping strategies quite like sports fans of perfected coping strategies. People often ask me, what's the craziest thing about sports fans? I really believe that the craziest thing about sports fans is that there actually are sports fans. This has to be the only domain, the only voluntary activity,
他们全心全意地关注球队，却只是一个无所事事的旁观者，心想，我真希望今天的事情能朝着我希望的方向发展。这并不完全像是我在投罚球，或者是我在挥棒。所以他们有一种无助感，当他们输球时，这种无助感会加剧挫败感。但如果这种情况发生，它的美妙之处在于，我认为没有人像体育迷那样完善了应对策略。人们经常问我，体育迷最疯狂的事情是什么？我真的认为体育迷最疯狂的事情是，他们竟然是体育迷。这一定是唯一的领域，唯一的自愿活动，
half the people know literally that they're going to be upset when this thing that they consume voluntarily is over, right? They know that there's at least a 50-50 chance that when they're done, I'm going to be sad. I'm not going to want to go to work tomorrow on and on and on. And yet they still coming back. You would never do that if it was like delivery pizza. If like half the time they delivered your pizza late, cold and the wrong pizza, you would not keep going back. Sports fans, we just keep going back and we keep going back because we cope so well. We can look back on the glory years and it makes us feel better about the fact that our team is terrible now.
一半的人实际上知道，当他们自愿消费的这个东西结束时，他们会感到沮丧，对吧？他们知道至少有50%的机会，当他们看完后，我会感到难过。我明天不想去上班等等。然而他们还是会回来。如果这是像送披萨一样，你永远不会这样做。如果他们有一半的时间送来的披萨是迟到的、冷的，而且送错了，你肯定不会再点。体育迷，我们只是不断地回来，因为我们应对得很好。我们可以回顾辉煌岁月，这让我们对球队现在表现糟糕的事实感觉好一些。
Or we can look to the future and see the future as being even more exciting than it is now. I mean, after all, my team is the worst team in the NFL. Hey, that's good news because that means I have the best pick and the draft upcoming, right? So we just have this way of convincing ourselves that it's all going to be okay. It's not okay now, but it's going to be okay in the future. And that's why fans, they just keep coming back. Again, I talk to lots of fans. and they so often tell me after losses, I'm never coming back.
或者我们可以展望未来，看到未来比现在更令人兴奋。我的意思是，毕竟，我的球队是NFL中最差的球队。嘿，那是好消息，因为这意味着我在即将到来的选秀中有最好的签位，对吧？所以我们只是有办法说服自己，一切都会好起来的。现在不好，但未来会好起来的。这就是为什么粉丝们不断回来。再说一次，我和很多粉丝交谈过。他们在输球后经常告诉我，我再也不会回来了。
100% of them have come back. That's great. What about the impact of betting on sports fans? Those who bet are invested in a different way. What's going on with them and when they win or lose what's happening psychologically? Yeah. You know, it's interesting. As I look back on the history of sport and then, of course, the history of fan that comes
他们100%都回来了。那太棒了。那么博彩对体育迷有什么影响呢？那些下注的人以不同的方式投入其中。他们身上发生了什么，当他们赢或输时，心理上发生了什么？是的。你知道，这很有趣。当我回顾体育的历史，当然还有随之而来的粉丝历史，
with it, it seems like every decade or two, There's a major change in how sport is played out that greatly impacts how fans consume and relate to teams and players and leagues and sports in general. You can think of when night games started, when sport got on TV, when free agency occurred and all of a sudden my favorite team is somehow now pitching for the rival team that I hate so much. I think that the new thing that we're looking at now is the fact that what was once an absolute giant no-no, which is betting on. on professional sports is now not just available, but embraced by the leagues who just a few short years ago thought that, you know, this was the worst thing that could possibly happen, that if individuals start to bet on sports, it's going to change how they're a sports fan. It's going to change how they follow teams.
似乎每十年或二十年，体育运动的进行方式就会发生重大变化，这极大地影响了粉丝消费和与球队、球员、联盟以及体育运动整体相关联的方式。你可以想到夜间比赛开始的时候，体育节目出现在电视上的时候，自由球员制度出现的时候，突然间我最喜欢的球队的投手现在竟然为我非常讨厌的对手球队投球。我认为我们现在正在关注的新事物是，曾经绝对禁止的事情，即对职业体育进行博彩，现在不仅可用，而且被那些几年前还认为这是可能发生的最糟糕事情的联盟所拥抱。他们认为，如果个人开始对体育进行博彩，这会改变他们作为体育迷的方式。这会改变他们关注球队的方式。
And they realize that, you know what, maybe it slightly does change how they follow sport and how they follow teams, but guess what? They do it more often because they have placed. to bet, and that's really good news for the sports leagues. It's kind of surprising those that followed fans and studied for Solomon. It took the leagues that long to come around to realize that, hey, betting fans are, guess what, betting fans, so they're going to consume your product. You've actually conducted some pretty interesting studies that has looked at how we would
他们意识到，你知道吗，也许这确实稍微改变了他们关注体育和球队的方式，但你猜怎么着？他们这样做的频率更高了，因为他们有地方下注，这对体育联盟来说真是个好消息。那些关注粉丝并研究粉丝的人感到有些惊讶。联盟花了那么长时间才意识到，嘿，下注的粉丝，你猜怎么着，他们是下注的粉丝，所以他们会消费你的产品。你实际上进行了一些非常有趣的研究，观察了我们
expect betting to change fandom. We talked to fans, okay, if and when they legalize sport wagering, you know, how will that change your perspective as a fan. And the bottom line from that research is it's really not going to do much, to be honest with you. It's not going to change a lot of individuals. The people that don't follow sport that could not care less about sport, they're not going to suddenly start following sport because you can bet.
预期博彩会如何改变粉丝文化。我们与粉丝交谈，好吧，如果且当他们将体育博彩合法化时，你作为粉丝的视角会发生什么变化。这项研究的底线是，老实说，它真的不会有太大影响。它不会改变很多个人。那些不关注体育、对体育一点也不关心的人，不会因为你可以下注就突然开始关注体育。
And the people that live for sport, they're not going to stop following sport because they can bet. They just might slightly consume some games that they wouldn't otherwise have watched, right? It would give them a reason to care about a game that their team is not playing or a rival team is not playing. So what our findings are, basically, it would slightly increase the interest for some fans. Fans that are lower on the scale of interest but still consider themselves a sport, these are the
而那些为体育而活的人，他们不会因为可以投注就停止关注体育。他们可能只是会稍微多看一些原本不会看的比赛，对吧？这会给他们一个理由去关心一场并非他们支持的球队或对手球队参加的比赛。所以我们的研究结果基本上是，这会稍微增加一些球迷的兴趣。那些兴趣程度较低，但仍认为自己是体育迷的人，这些人是
ones that say, you know what, it might make me a little nervous or too anxious, so I might not want to do it. So the moderate fans are like, I don't really need a reason to care in a way that's financially going to damage me. So, but for the, your typical, I love my team. fan, it just gives them one more reason to follow. What about when fans find out that somebody or even a whole team they revered was cheating, was doing something wrong, was doping like Lance Armstrong, for example?
那些会说，你知道吗，这可能会让我有点紧张或焦虑，所以我可能不想参与。所以中度球迷会觉得，我真的不需要一个在经济上会损害我的理由去关心。但是对于那种典型的“我爱我的球队”的球迷来说，这只是给了他们多一个关注的理由。那么，当球迷发现他们崇拜的人甚至整个球队在作弊、做错事、像兰斯·阿姆斯特朗那样服用兴奋剂时，会发生什么呢？
What happens to fans then? Yeah, it really depends on their level of identification. Again, their level of psychological connection to the team. If they're low in identification or moderate, so maybe it's a team that they sort of associate with or maybe they sort of follow their progress over the course of a year. But certainly it would not be something that they would highly self-identify as a fan of that team. For these individuals, they tend to put down the team of the player and it's going to decrease
那时球迷会怎么样？是的，这真的取决于他们的认同程度。再说一次，是他们与球队的心理联系程度。如果他们的认同感较低或中等，可能只是他们某种程度上关联的球队，或者他们可能在一年中关注一下球队的进展。但肯定不是那种他们会高度自我认同为该队球迷的情况。对于这些人，他们往往会看轻该球员所在的球队，这会降低
their likelihood of wanting to be associated with that team. The term that we use in social psychology is cutting off reflected failure. They will cut off their association, at least psychologically and publicly with that team. You know, we really, you often hear people say, we're known by the company we keep. And I always tell my students that that's not the point. The point isn't that we're known by the company we keep. The point is that we know that we are known by the company we keep. We realize that fact.
他们想要与该球队产生关联的可能性。我们在社会心理学中使用的术语是“切断反射性失败”。他们会切断与该球队的联系，至少在心理上和公开场合是这样。你知道，你经常听到人们说，我们通过我们交往的对象来了解。我总是告诉我的学生，重点不在这里。重点不是我们通过交往对象被了解，重点是我们知道我们是通过交往对象被了解的。我们意识到了这个事实。
And so that knowledge changes our behavior and nobody wants to be associated with someone that has done something negative or illegal or that is like threatened the quality of this identity. Not nobody, actually, because those that are highly identified, you just have to wonder, you know, studying this for four decades, what do players and teams have to do to finally convince somebody that they are not worthy of their love? You know, it's like, I mean, steroids and DUIs and on and on and on. And there's still fan bases that hold on to those individuals. And once again, they do so because they have perfected coping. They've figured out a way to, you know, externalize the individuals' transgression. Well, you know, they're under a lot of pressure.
所以这种认知改变了我们的行为，没有人愿意与做了负面、非法事情或威胁到这种身份认同质量的人联系在一起。其实也不是没有人，因为那些高度认同的人，你不得不怀疑，你知道，研究这个四十年了，球员和球队到底要做什么才能最终让某人相信他们不值得他们的爱？你知道，我的意思是，类固醇、酒驾等等等等。仍然有球迷群体坚持支持这些人。再一次，他们这样做是因为他们完善了应对机制。他们找到了一种方法，你知道，将个人的越轨行为外化。嗯，你知道，他们承受着很大的压力。
They're under a lot of stress. Or, well, everybody does it. Or they actually weren't guilty. There was an Olympian a few years ago, several years ago now that was actually caught doping, performance enhancing drugs. And huge fans of this sprinter, one of the more common explanations, they had was that the rival runners, sprinters, had actually switched out his water bottle and put out a water bottle that had the performance enhancing drugs in it. And they weren't just like making this up. They were literally convinced, right? So the ability of sports fans to find a way to make it all fit and be okay is what allows them to continue to support these individuals. Now, again, they're not completely foolish. And they,
他们承受着很大的压力。或者，嗯，每个人都这么做。或者他们其实并没有罪。几年前，几年前现在有位奥林匹克选手实际上被抓到服用兴奋剂，即提高成绩的药物。这位短跑运动员的忠实粉丝，他们最常见的解释之一是，竞争对手的跑步者、短跑运动员实际上换了他的水瓶，放了一个装有提高成绩药物的水瓶。他们并不是在编造。他们确实是深信不疑，对吧？所以体育迷能够找到一种方式让这一切变得合理并接受它，这使他们能够继续支持这些人。现在，再说一次，他们并不完全愚蠢。而且他们，
understand that, you know, when somebody does something, they'll say they shouldn't have done that. They really shouldn't have done that. That was a horrible thing to do. Then they follow that up with, but I'm a forgiving soul. And so it's all okay with me. Why do some people root for underdogs and other people always want to be on the bandwagon with the winning team? Yeah, it's so interesting how when you look at people, they either want to pick the surefire winner or, the gross underdog. It's like they don't want to pick the team that's 50-50. And the reason is both of those two, picking the high favorite or the serious underdog,
明白，你知道，当某人做了一些事时，他们会说他不应该那样做。他真的不应该那样做。那是一件可怕的事情。然后他们接着说，但我是一个宽容的人。所以对我来说一切都好。为什么有些人支持弱者，而另一些人总是想加入获胜球队的行列？是的，观察人们是多么有趣，他们要么想选择稳赢的球队，要么想选择极端的弱者。就像他们不想选择胜算五五开的球队一样。原因在于这两者，选择高热门球队或严重的弱者，
the long shot, both of those two are so psychologically safe. If you pick a team that is slated to be like a 95% likelihood to win, that's a safe selection. So is picking the team that's a 5% likelihood to win. because should that team lose, and it looks like they're going to, you can very easily say, hey, you know, they had no chance. Now, the advantage is if you pick the underdog and they lose, you can say that, right? You can say, well, let's be honest. They never really had a chance.
那个胜算极低的球队，这两者在心理上都是非常安全的。如果你选择一支被认为有95%胜算的球队，那是一个安全的选择。选择一支只有5%胜算的球队也是如此。因为如果那支球队输了，而且看起来他们确实会输，你可以很容易地说，嘿，你知道，他们根本没有机会。现在，优势在于如果你选择了弱者而他们输了，你可以那样说，对吧？你可以说，好吧，说实话。他们从来没有真正的机会。
Ah, but if they win, isn't that victory that much sweeter? Isn't that victory that much better because it's unexpected? So I always say that that's where rooting for the underdog, relative to a favorite team rooting to the underdog. That's a win-win. If they lose, hey, it's okay. We're the lovable losers. We're supposed to.
啊，但如果他们赢了，那场胜利不是更甜美吗？那场胜利不是因为出人意料而更好吗？所以我总是说，这就是支持弱者相对于支持热门球队的优势所在。这是一个双赢。如果他们输了，嘿，没关系。我们是可爱的失败者。我们本该如此。
If we win, oh my gosh, how in the world do we pull that off? One of the best victories ever. Yeah. It's amazing how people like safe choices. Underdogs are safe choices. It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose GoogleFi Wireless.
如果我们赢了，天哪，我们到底是怎么做到的？有史以来最好的胜利之一。是的。人们喜欢安全的选择真是太神奇了。弱者是安全的选择。现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务扩展很快。为了保持花蜜流动，我需要一个具有最高优先级数据速度的电话套餐。这就是我选择GoogleFi Wireless的原因。
My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now, that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore GoogleFi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees. Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. What about the effect of fans on teams themselves? I mentioned in the intro, the home field advantage.
即使在蜂巢嗡嗡作响时，我的连接依然强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月35美元起。那真是一个不会持续太久的优惠。立即探索GoogleFi Wireless套餐。另加税费和政府费用。Google Fi Wireless在网络高使用率期间不受数据流量降级限制。那么球迷对球队本身的影响呢？我在介绍中提到了主场优势。
Is it a real thing? Absolutely. So there's a few ways that research over the years, over the decades, mostly from social psychology, has examined, do crowds matter, right? I mean, certainly they matter to the bottom line and the pocketbooks of the people that own the teams and leagues, but do they actually matter on the field in terms of performance? And there's a couple of ways that they do. Certainly, social facilitation, the fact that being around others can kind of get people to rise to the occasion or maybe choke under pressure. sure that can have a play in this. But I think that from a sports psych perspective,
这是真实存在的吗？绝对是。所以多年来，几十年来，主要来自社会心理学的研究通过几种方式检验了观众是否重要，对吧？我的意思是，他们当然对球队和联盟所有者的底线和钱包很重要，但他们在球场上的表现方面真的重要吗？他们确实有几种方式产生影响。当然，社会促进作用，即身处他人周围可以促使人们超常发挥，或者在压力下表现失常。当然，这可以在其中发挥作用。但我认为从运动心理学的角度来看，
most individuals do want to talk about and think about, is there this home field advantage? It is one of the most well-replicated and substantiated findings in the realm of sports psychology, that home teams, they just do win more. It doesn't matter the level of competition. It doesn't matter the type of sport. Home teams are going to win more.
大多数人确实想谈论和思考的是，是否存在这种主场优势？这是运动心理学领域中最被重复验证和证实的发现之一，主场球队确实赢球更多。无论竞争水平如何，无论运动类型如何。主场球队赢球更多。
typically about 60 to 40 home teams will have an advantage. And they have over the decades put forth several potential explanations for this. One popular one, a few decades back was travel and fatigue. Well, you know, traveling several hours, you know, by plane is probably going to wear them down. I mean, have you looked at the planes these people travel on? They're nicer than my house. I mean, I don't know. They probably get to the hotel and look around and go, this five-star hotel is a done.
通常大约60比40，主场球队会有优势。几十年来，他们为此提出了几种可能的解释。几十年前一个流行的解释是旅行和疲劳。嗯，你知道，乘飞机旅行几个小时，可能会让他们感到疲惫。我的意思是，你见过这些人乘坐的飞机吗？它们比我的房子还要好。我的意思是，我不知道。他们可能到了酒店，环顾四周，说，这家五星级酒店真是太棒了。
compare the airplane that we were just in. And so all these other sort of potential explanations, they might matter a little bit. But what research in the last maybe 10 years has found is that what fans are doing is they're influencing the outcomes of the calls of the officials, that the officials are the ones far more than the players that are being influenced by the fans. A great example of this, there's lots of research. A great example of this is some researchers found that there's actually a home field advantage in Olympics. But they don't find it for objective sports like the 100 meter dash. They find it for subjective sports like gymnastics and diving, where the judges have such a huge impact on the outcome.
比较一下我们刚才乘坐的飞机。所以所有这些其他潜在的解释，它们可能有一点影响。但过去大约10年的研究发现，球迷所做的是他们正在影响裁判的判罚结果，裁判比球员更容易受到球迷的影响。一个很好的例子，有很多研究。一个很好的例子是，一些研究人员发现奥运会中实际上存在主场优势。但他们没有在像100米短跑这样的客观运动中发现它。他们在像体操和跳水这样的主观运动中发现了它，裁判对结果有巨大的影响。
That's where they find the home foot advantage, where the officials really do have the biggest say. In football games, some football stadiums will have a track, a running track, like the track meet track around the football stadiums. Others don't have that. get a higher home field advantage when that track is not there because the fans are that much closer to the officials and they have that much more of an influence on the officials. So what we know is, yes, the home field advantage is alive and well and an honest thing. And it looks like from the current state of the research that the big impact is not on the players themselves as a message
这就是他们发现主场优势的地方，裁判确实有最大的发言权。在足球比赛中，一些足球场会有跑道，像田径场那样的跑道环绕着足球场。其他的则没有。当没有跑道时，主场优势更高，因为球迷离裁判更近，他们对裁判的影响力更大。所以我们知道的是，是的，主场优势是真实存在的。从目前的研究状况来看，大的影响不是对球员本身，而是
it's on the fans having influence on the decisions that the umpires and the referees are making. Are there common traits among certain types of fans? For instance, do some people become fans because they have low self-esteem and they need some external validation? Or do people with, say, violent tendencies revere boxing and mixed martial arts? We've been looking for the, like the recipe for a sports fan for a long time in sports psychology. And I'm sad to say we have not yet found it. time we think we might have found when somebody else comes along as a sports fan and they're completely different. If you go to a stadium that has as few as 150, 200 people in that stadium
是对球迷影响裁判和裁判员的判罚。某些类型的球迷之间是否有共同特征？例如，有些人成为球迷是因为他们自尊心低，需要一些外部认可吗？或者具有暴力倾向的人是否崇拜拳击和综合格斗？我们在运动心理学中寻找体育迷的“配方”已经很长时间了。我很遗憾地说，我们还没有找到它。每次我们认为可能找到了，就会出现另一个完全不同的体育迷。如果你去一个只有150、200人的体育场
watching a game, you're going to find every single different personality trait possible among those 150 and 200 people. Now, does that mean that we haven't found certain characteristics of sports fans in research? I mean, we have, right? So, for example, sports fans tend to slide slightly towards an extroverted crowd. That makes sense because, you know, most sports fans, they will consume in the public scenario. But when you look at how much variance is accounted for, right, how powerful these effects are, it's just minuscule, right?
观看比赛，你会在这150到200人中发现每一种可能的人格特质。现在，这是否意味着我们在研究中没有发现体育迷的某些特征？我的意思是，我们发现了，对吧？例如，体育迷往往稍微偏向外向型人群。这说得通，因为你知道，大多数体育迷会在公共场合消费。但当你观察解释了多少方差，对吧，这些影响有多强大时，它只是微不足道的，对吧？
And so what we really say now is that, sure, maybe individuals who tend towards a preference for stylistic things in life would lean towards, I don't know, diving, gymnastics, figure skating, that maybe that's there. But it's such a small effect that you're way better off saying every kind of person seems to like every kind of sport out there. We did some research a few years ago where we thought, you know what, I bet there should be a scenario where fans that are, they're really into it because of the family nature of sport that they see sport as an opportunity to spend time with their kids and their spouses. We thought those people, they really shouldn't like violent sports, right? That doesn't seem like it should fit.
所以我们现在真正说的是，当然，也许在生活中偏好风格化事物的人会倾向于，我不知道，跳水、体操、花样滑冰，也许这存在。但这种影响太小了，以至于说每种人似乎都喜欢每种运动要好得多。几年前我们做了一些研究，我们认为，你知道吗，我打赌应该有一种情况，那些因为体育的家庭性质而真正投入其中的球迷，他们将体育视为与孩子和配偶共度时光的机会。我们认为这些人，他们真的不应该喜欢暴力运动，对吧？这看起来不应该合适。
Nope, not at all. We absolutely found that they don't care at all, that they're going to take their kids to the track meet and they're going to take their kids to the bowling alley and they're going to take them to the professional wrestling match. It literally did not matter to these people. We also thought that, well, maybe instead they would like stylistic sports, you know, and nope, didn't matter. It just every kind of person that you can imagine seems like every different kind of sport that there's out there. And when you factor in how many, you know, millions and millions and millions of fans there are in the world, that kind of starts to make some sense. Yeah. When does fandom cross the line into something unhealthy?
不，一点也不。我们绝对发现他们根本不在乎，他们会带孩子去田径比赛，带孩子去保龄球馆，带他们去看职业摔跤比赛。这对这些人来说根本不重要。我们还认为，嗯，也许他们会喜欢风格化的运动，你知道，不，没关系。每一种你能想象到的人似乎都喜欢那里存在的每一种不同的运动。当你考虑到世界上有数以亿计的球迷时，这开始变得有意义了。是的。球迷行为何时会越界变成不健康的事情？
assuming that it sometimes does. Anytime you have individuals that can get as wrapped up into something as some fans can get into sport, you're going to have individuals who cross the line. I always refer to this as the darker side of sport fandom. I think that it's critical that we talk about this. I think that it's critical that we don't only talk about this. I think that that was one of the, I mean, it was a criticism of psychology, right? I mean, for so long, we just didn't want to really talk about the good sides of humanity.
假设有时确实会发生。任何时候，当个人像一些球迷投入体育那样投入某件事时，你就会有越界的人。我总是称之为体育迷的阴暗面。我认为讨论这一点至关重要。我认为我们不仅要讨论这一点至关重要。我认为那是心理学的一个批评，对吧？我的意思是，长期以来，我们只是不想真正谈论人性的好的一面。
Positive psychology comes along, you know, three, four decades ago and, you know, kind of lets us know, hey, it's okay to talk about high self-esteem as well as low self-esteem. That's a good thing. It's a good thing to talk about what sport fandom does positively, but we also have to be honest and admit that, you know, there are times when sports fans do things that cross the line. I think certainly sport fan aggression is the obvious thing at the top of this list. that there are fans that, I mean, they do things that they should not do. I mean, they hurl things at players.
积极心理学在三、四十年前出现，你知道，让我们知道，嘿，谈论高自尊和低自尊都是可以的。这是一件好事。谈论体育迷带来的积极影响是一件好事，但我们也必须诚实并承认，你知道，有时体育迷的行为会越界。我认为体育迷的攻击性无疑是这个列表的首位。有些球迷，我的意思是，他们做了一些他们不该做的事。我的意思是，他们向球员投掷东西。
They say things at players and they get in fights with fans. And it is not a pretty sight when it occurs. It is rare. So one of the things, in addition to the fact that sports fandom can have this facilitating effect for some individuals on aggression where they get too wrapped up in the moment at the sporting event, we can also see some of the darker side in terms of. of their interpersonal relationships and their lack of care about their job, that we actually have individuals out there that they'll admit that they will consume sport
他们对球员说些什么，并与球迷打架。当这种情况发生时，景象并不美观。这很少见。所以，除了体育迷对某些人的攻击性有促进作用，使他们在体育赛事中过于投入之外，我们还可以看到一些阴暗面，体现在他们的人际关系和对工作缺乏关心上，我们实际上有这样的人，他们会承认他们会消费体育
over 100 hours a week. And if you consume something 100 hours a week, that doesn't give a whole lot of time for, I mean, a loved one, your kids, a job, sleep, food. It doesn't give a whole lot of time for anything. And so I think that we, again, we have to admit that these things are there. very small percentage. Most individuals, they will say that sport fandom is a positive influence on their relationship. About two or three percent will say it probably has some type of detrimental effect. But again, if you're going to say that one fight in a crowd is too many, I'm going to say
每周超过100小时。如果你每周消费100小时，那留给爱人、孩子、工作、睡眠、食物的时间就不多了。这几乎没有时间做任何事情。所以我认为我们再次必须承认这些事情是存在的。比例非常小。大多数人会说体育迷对他们的关系有积极影响。大约百分之二或三的人会说它可能有一些负面影响。但再说一次，如果你要说观众席上的一次打架就太多了，我会说
that two percent of individuals having their lives negatively impacted by fandom is two percent too many. It shouldn't have that negative effect. And so we need to talk about the darker side as well. we need to be honest with ourselves and say, okay, can we do things that lower these numbers, that move the needle? Because if 2% have a negative impact for fandom on their interpersonal relationships, that means there's 2% of relationship partners, right? Two percent of families. If you have one fight in the stands, okay, fine, that's two people, maybe three people, four people, but that's dozens of people around that individual who had their, positive experience seriously interrupted. And they can feel threatened by this. And we know that
百分之二的人因粉丝文化而生活受到负面影响，这个比例已经太高了。它不应该产生这种负面影响。因此，我们也需要谈谈阴暗面。我们需要诚实地面对自己，说，好吧，我们能做些什么来降低这些数字，从而产生影响吗？因为如果 2% 的人在人际关系中受到粉丝文化的负面影响，这意味着有 2% 的伴侣，对吧？2% 的家庭。如果你在看台上打了一架，好吧，没关系，那是两个人，也许三个人，四个人，但那个人周围有几十个人，他们的积极体验受到了严重干扰。他们会因此感到受到威胁。我们知道
one incidence like this is enough to make some individuals shy away from coming back. It puts a bad taste in their mouth. And so just because it's, you know, vastly in the minority, that doesn't mean it isn't worthy of our attention and isn't potentially impacting more people in total than you might think. Is this kind of aggression among people? fans on the increase? Boy, wouldn't we love to know that? So, been giving these interviews for the better part of three and a half decades, that is for certain, the most common question that I get. And it is awful to answer the most common question that you get for one third of a century by saying, we don't know.
像这样的事件发生一次就足以让一些人望而却步，不敢再来。这让他们留下了不好的印象。所以，仅仅因为它在少数，并不意味着它不值得我们关注，也不意味着它对总人数的影响可能比你想象的要大。这种粉丝之间的攻击性在增加吗？天哪，我们多想知道这一点啊！所以，在过去三十年半的大部分时间里，我一直在接受这些采访，这无疑是我被问到最多的问题。在一个世纪的三分之一时间里，对最常见的问题回答说“我们不知道”，这感觉太糟糕了。
I wish I had an answer, but I just do not want to lie and not reflect the research. And in this case, what research? how would we ever know, right? So when we define aggression among fans, it counts if you're yelling obscenities, as it should. It counts if you're yelling obscenities. There's nobody in the stands with a clicker, right? Counting obscenities. Probably there should be, right?
我希望我有答案，但我只是不想撒谎，也不想不反映研究结果。在这种情况下，什么研究？我们怎么可能知道呢，对吧？所以当我们定义粉丝之间的攻击性时，如果你在辱骂，它就算作攻击，理应如此。如果你在辱骂，它就算作攻击。看台上没有人拿着计数器，对吧？在统计辱骂次数。也许应该有人统计，对吧？
Maybe we don't want to know those numbers. But I can say this. There are certainly a lot of theoretical perspectives out there that would suggest that, yes, sport fan aggression is on the rise. We might not have absolute concrete numbers, but we know things that would suggest that it should be. For example, we know that team identification can play a role in aggression, and we know that people are now more likely to identify with sports teams than there were maybe 20, 40, 60 years ago because other social institutions with which they used to identify work, extended family living close to home, attending religious institutions. these things can be on the decline. Something has to take the place of that, right?
也许我们不想知道那些数字。但我可以这么说。肯定有很多理论观点认为，是的，体育迷的攻击性正在上升。我们可能没有绝对具体的数字，但我们知道一些迹象表明它应该在上升。例如，我们知道团队认同感可以在攻击性中发挥作用，而且我们知道，与 20、40、60 年前相比，人们现在更有可能认同运动队，因为他们过去认同的其他社会机构——工作、住在附近的大家庭、参加宗教机构——这些东西可能正在衰落。总得有什么东西来代替它，对吧？
We're not going to stop being, you know, social creatures. If fandom is chosen as the option to take the place of that, all of a sudden you care more about fandom. All of a sudden, you're more likely to get upset if they lose. Society, we're not as nice as we used to be. You know, empathy levels are going down, civility levels going down. People have traced this for many decades.
我们不会停止成为社会性生物。如果粉丝文化被选为替代方案，突然之间，你就会更关心粉丝文化。突然之间，如果他们输了，你更有可能感到不安。社会，我们不像过去那么友善了。你知道，同理心水平在下降，文明水平在下降。人们已经追踪了几十年了。
If society has less civility, why would we expect there to be anything different among the fans and stadiums, right? So I can't say, yes, in 2019, the number was this. And in 2014, it was this. But I can tell you, theories matter. And we know that there are several theories that would suggest that, yeah, it's on the rise. And then you can also just say, go to a sporting event, trying to remember what it was like, you know, 25, 45, 55 years ago. It doesn't feel the same.
如果社会文明程度降低，我们为什么期望粉丝和体育场内会有所不同呢，对吧？所以我不能说，是的，2019 年数字是这个，2014 年是那个。但我可以告诉你，理论很重要。我们知道有几种理论表明，是的，它正在上升。然后你也可以说，去参加一场体育赛事，试着回忆一下 25、45、55 年前是什么样子。感觉不一样了。
Right. Right. Fifty five years ago, they didn't have family sections. They have to have family sections now because they have to, they have to like quarantine the people who don't want to be exposed to all the rowdy and dysfunctional fans. That should tell you that, yeah, maybe something not so pleasant is going on. Sure, sure. And the men were wearing suits and the women were wearing dresses. Exactly. Different world. Yeah. Now, I've read, speaking of age, I've read some reporting that younger people are less likely to be sports fans now than older generation. There was a recent article in USA today that was called Gen Z doesn't care about sports. Does that track with your experience and research? And if it does, what do you think is causing this? There's no doubt that that's true. As a matter of fact, one of the recent conversations I had with some of the administration
对。对。55 年前，他们没有家庭区。他们现在必须有家庭区，因为他们必须，他们必须像隔离那些不想接触所有吵闹和功能失调的粉丝的人一样。这应该告诉你，是的，也许正在发生一些不那么愉快的事情。当然，当然。男人们穿着西装，女人们穿着裙子。完全正确。不同的世界。是的。现在，说到年龄，我读到一些报道称，年轻人现在比老一代人更不容易成为体育迷。《今日美国》最近有一篇文章叫《Z 世代不关心体育》。这与你的经验和研究相符吗？如果相符，你认为是什么原因造成的？毫无疑问这是真的。事实上，我最近与一些行政部门的谈话之一
in our university's athletic department was that, you know, we draw pretty well for our men's basketball team. Murray State historically has had a pretty good men's basketball team. And we'll get, you know, five, six, seven thousand fans for a typical game, not bad for a mid-major university. And I, you know, I told our athletic director, said, if I were you, I'd be nervous because when you look around, you know, they're all in their 40s and 50s and 60s. You don't see very, very, very few in their 20s at these sporting events. And certainly, you know, not in their teens. there are so many things that individuals that are 15, 20, 25, that they had an opportunity to do and get exposed to when they were growing up that older generations did not, right?
在我们大学的体育部门，你知道，我们的男子篮球队吸引力相当不错。默里州立大学历史上一直有一支相当不错的男子篮球队。典型的比赛我们会吸引五、六、七千名粉丝，对于一所中等规模的大学来说还不错。我，你知道，我告诉我们的体育主管，我说，如果我是你，我会很紧张，因为当你环顾四周时，你知道，他们都在 40 多岁、50 多岁和 60 多岁。你在这些体育赛事中几乎看不到 20 多岁的人。当然，肯定没有十几岁的人。对于 15、20、25 岁的人来说，他们成长过程中有机会做和接触的事情太多了，而老一辈人却没有，对吧？
There are just more entertainment options that are out there. When I grew up, you had ABC, CBS, NBC, and pretty much that was it. On a good day, maybe PBS would come in, but that was about it. And so now how many different options just on TV and streaming and on and on? There's such a competition for the entertainment time for the younger generations that we didn't have. So less likely to be socialized into sport fandom because they're more likely to be doing other things, right? There's no doubt that this is true. Sport fandom is going to be very interesting in about.
外面有更多的娱乐选择。我成长的时候，你有 ABC、CBS、NBC，基本上就是这些了。运气好的话，也许能收到 PBS，但也就这样了。所以现在光是电视和流媒体就有多少种不同的选择？对于年轻一代来说，娱乐时间的竞争非常激烈，我们当时没有。所以他们不太可能被社会化为体育迷，因为他们更有可能做其他事情，对吧？毫无疑问这是真的。大约在
30 years when the people that buy tickets are no longer around to buy the tickets, I doubt I'll be here to see that. If I am, I'm really curiously how that plays out because it's just fandom is aging out. Phantom is aging out. And I'm not saying that there aren't young individuals who are fans. There are. But just look at a stadium. I mean, it's an older crowd relative to what it used to be.
30 年后，当买票的人不再存在时，体育粉丝文化将会非常有趣。我怀疑我是否还能看到那一天。如果我还在，我真的很好奇事情会如何发展，因为粉丝文化正在老龄化。粉丝文化正在老龄化。我并不是说没有年轻的粉丝。有。但看看体育场吧。我的意思是，相对于过去，这是一个更年长的群体。
And younger individuals, they have more opportunities. They have more things to do, and so they're less likely to care about any one thing. So is this trend having an impact on your course enrollment? It does not, thankfully, because there's always enough fans that are out there. Interestingly enough, I have about 20% of my sport fan psychology class that are absolutely not sports fans, that they detest sport, they've never followed it, and they don't understand. it. And so they take the class to try and figure out what in the world is going on with all these people that are putting all this time and money, you know, into these activities. And it's funny because
而且年轻人，他们有更多的机会。他们有更多的事情要做，所以他们不太可能关心任何一件事。那么这种趋势对你的课程注册有影响吗？谢天谢地，没有，因为外面总有足够的粉丝。有趣的是，我的体育粉丝心理学课上大约有 20% 的人绝对不是体育迷，他们讨厌体育，他们从未关注过，也不理解它。所以他们选修这门课是为了弄清楚这些把所有时间和金钱投入到这些活动中的人到底是怎么回事。这很有趣，因为
they'll be apologetic about taking the class. And I tell them, no, I can't have enough of you people in this class because you give the counterbalance to class discussions, right? If it's just all a bunch of sports fans, the class discussion becomes preaching to the choir. The fact that I have three or four or five non-fans in there, it sort of serves as a check and a balance to the other individuals. And it really makes them do some type of, you know, self-awareness test of, yeah, why do I do so much of this? Apparently not everybody does. And it gets for much better conversations. So in the past few years, a lot of athletes have become more open about their mental health struggles. Do you think that this trend is changing the way that fans relate to athletes and the way
他们会对选修这门课感到抱歉。我告诉他们，不，我这门课上不能没有你们这样的人，因为你们为课堂讨论提供了平衡，对吧？如果全是一群体育迷，课堂讨论就变成了向唱诗班布道。我有三四个非粉丝在里面，这在某种程度上起到了制衡作用。这确实让他们进行某种自我意识测试，即，是的，为什么我做了这么多这种事？显然不是每个人都这样。这带来了更好的对话。所以在过去几年里，很多运动员对他们的心理健康斗争变得更加开放。你认为这种趋势正在改变粉丝与运动员的关系以及他们
that they think about sports in general? You know, as a social scientist, I certainly hope so. I think that sports fans, you know, they're certainly slow to come around. I mean, let's just be honest, right? I mean, you change your team's logo, just the logo. And for like 20 years, they can't get over what a distrustful and awful. scenario that was, right? That's just the picture of some creature. And for years, we know that athletes were taught to, you know, suck it up, don't cry, this and that. I hope that athletes, by coming out, are changing how fans view athletes and that they're not animals, that they're not robots, that they're actually humans, that they have feelings, that they are fallible,
思考体育的方式吗？你知道，作为一名社会科学家，我当然希望如此。我认为体育迷，你知道，他们肯定反应迟钝。我的意思是，让我们诚实一点，对吧？我的意思是，你改变了你球队的标志，仅仅是标志。然后有 20 年的时间，他们无法释怀那是一个多么令人不信任和糟糕的场景，对吧？那只是一张某种生物的图片。多年来，我们知道运动员被教导要忍气吞声，不要哭，诸如此类。我希望运动员通过公开，正在改变粉丝看待运动员的方式，他们不是动物，他们不是机器人，他们实际上是人类，他们有感情，他们会犯错，
and that what they're doing, their performance is in the public eye. Everybody gets to see when they have a bad day. And I think that a lot of fans would be really upset if everybody, and by everybody, I mean literally millions of people get to see when you messed up at work. I think that that might change their perspective. My hope is that individuals see the humanity in athletics. And that we start to give these people a little bit of slack that, you know what, it's okay for them to be human too. I mean, it should be.
而且他们所做的事情，他们的表现是在公众视野中的。当他们度过糟糕的一天时，每个人都能看到。我认为如果每个人——我指的是字面上的数百万人——都能看到你在工作中搞砸了，很多粉丝会非常不安。我认为这可能会改变他们的观点。我的希望是人们能看到运动员的人性。我们开始给这些人一点宽容，你知道吗，他们也是人，这没关系。我的意思是，本该如此。
They are human. Yeah. Like Simone Biles getting the twisties. Exactly. And you know what? As it comes out more and fans get more used to it, more athletes will then feel empowered to come out and it will seem less abnormal. and then that's that snowball that you hope you see over the next eight, 10, 12 years. So what's next for you?
他们是人。是的。就像西蒙·拜尔斯出现“空中失感”一样。完全正确。你知道吗？随着它越来越多地被曝光，粉丝们也越来越习惯，更多的运动员会感到有能力站出来，这看起来就不会那么不正常了。然后这就是你希望在未来 8、10、12 年里看到的滚雪球效应。那么你接下来要做什么？
What else are you looking at? What are the big questions? So what we've been looking at now actually is fans' beliefs about how they think they can influence the outcomes of sporting events. We know that they sort of can by, you know, maybe potentially have an impact on the players, but definitely having an impact on officials. Well, we've been asking them, what do you do to try and influence the outcome? So to what extent do you have superstitions, prayer, yell encouragement, yell derogatory comments towards the officials and the other team?
你还在关注什么？大问题是什么？所以我们现在实际上正在研究的是粉丝们关于他们认为自己如何能影响体育赛事结果的信念。我们知道他们可以通过，你知道，可能对球员产生潜在影响，但肯定对裁判有影响。好吧，我们一直在问他们，你做了什么来试图影响结果？那么你在多大程度上会有迷信、祈祷、大声鼓励、对裁判和对方球队大喊贬损评论？
And what we found was so interesting in the first study that's under review at a journal now is that all of the different methods that they use are positively correlated. So the more they use one method, the more they use another. That to me is absolutely hysterical because it means that the more someone is likely to cuss out an official to help the team win is also more likely to pray to help the team win. And somewhere, that to me is just so wonderfully funny. I can't get it, get past it. The stay that we're starting now that will begin this fall is now that we know that fans engage in these acts to try and influence, we're now asking them, which ones do you think work best, right? We know what they do.
我们在目前正在期刊审阅的第一项研究中发现，非常有趣的是，他们使用的所有不同方法都是正相关的。所以他们使用一种方法越多，他们使用另一种方法就越多。对我来说，这绝对是歇斯底里的，因为这意味着一个人越有可能为了帮助球队获胜而辱骂裁判，也就越有可能为了帮助球队获胜而祈祷。在某种程度上，这对我来说真是太有趣了。我无法释怀。我们现在开始的这项研究将在今年秋天开始，既然我们知道粉丝会采取这些行为来试图影响结果，我们现在正在问他们，你认为哪些方法最有效，对吧？我们知道他们做了什么。
Now, we'd like to know, okay, so, you know, pitchers have their go-to pitch, point guards have their go-to move. We want to know what the fans go-to active influence is when it's really close, right? When it's really close, do you cuss or do you pray or do you rub your lucky rabbit's foot? That's what we're after now. That's a great question. Well, Dr. Juan, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been a lot of fun.
现在，我们想知道，好吧，你知道，投手有他们的拿手球，控球后卫有他们的拿手动作。我们想知道当比赛非常接近时，粉丝们的拿手影响行为是什么，对吧？当比赛非常接近时，你是骂人，还是祈祷，还是摩擦你的幸运兔脚？这就是我们现在追求的目标。这是一个很好的问题。好吧，Juan 博士，我想感谢你今天加入我。这非常有趣。
Thank you. Absolutely been my pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne.
谢谢。这绝对是我的荣幸。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《Speaking of Psychology》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《Speaking of Psychology》由 Lee Wynerman 制作。我们的音效编辑是 Chris Condyenne。
Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。